What would cause lack of energy by fatigue has been overwhelming lately?
So a change in energy levels an increase in fatigue
If it's if it's sudden and it's
And it improves
Relatively quickly. Let's say I let's say I just was exhausted last week for about three days
I was just I just felt like I needed to take a nap during the day
I don't know what was wrong with it. It's just very odd
But I don't feel that anymore
Then then what was the cause of that? Well, it was probably nothing pathological
Meeting long-term pathological could have been you could have had a virus could have had some sort of other infection
Something like that could have had some adrenal fatigue from something
That's what you think of for intermittent lack of energy
But what a person has like all of a sudden they have fatigue more than usual and they start making the comments to themselves
Like what is wrong with me? I just feel like I need to take a nap
I'm just tired. I don't feel like I have the energy that I used to and this is more long-standing
And it's not going away. Okay, then that's where blood work comes in
So looking at blood work, you know, you personally you look at for this would be a CBC with a differential because
That would if you had an elevated white blood cell count, then it could be a
Chronic infection or a suppressed white blood cell count
With a diagnosis of cancer
Can still be an indication of a chronic viral infection
But the biggest thing you look at is the red blood cell markers and whether a person has anemia
So the biggest thing you want to look at with the person with a diagnosis of cancer is
You know do they have anemia as well now many people come to me and we get started on care
And they already have anemia
Well, we want to try to get the blood built up by helping get the person built up
And not just so tired at the mix. That's typical thing that you take more if I have anemia that I need to start taking iron
Well, not all anemias are iron deficiency anemias, but most anemias of chronic disease
Media anemias caused from cancer are iron deficiency anemias and we would look at the blood work depending on all those other
markers the RDW the
Total plane that percentage at all those things those other things in the
CBC would help us determine what type of anemia could it be a B12 anemia could it be a B6 anemia could it be a folate anemia?
But anemia of a chronic disease anemia that's associated with cancer is almost always going to be an iron deficiency
Anemia because the cancer is gobbling up iron and
That's leaving the person in a state of anemia and mild anemia is going to still
Cause a person to have fatigue even if you're even if you're red blood cell count is no role
But your hemoglobin and hematocrit are are
low it could give a person a relative state of fatigue and
The greater the about the greater degree of anemia is going to be the greater degree of fatigue and
We need to address that we need to deal with that. So
What would be the cause of lack of energy if it's long
Stating and getting worse. We want to get a blood work done CBC with differential
comprehensive
metabolic panel and
Look at our markers and see if things are going in a direction that we don't want to go because like I said
Same thing about the question of how do I know if I'm getting better or not or how do I know if I'm getting worse or not would be
Let's say I had blood work three months ago. Everything was normal pretend that now I do blood work and now I have anemia in everything
Three months ago wasn't even at the end of anemia. So this is you know my my red blood cell count my hemoglobin my hematocrit
Now their numbers are often my CBC
That's not a good thing. We need to address that. So
That's why getting regular blood work can be a good idea